>> Tucker: U.N. AMBASSADOR NIKKI
HALEY SURPRISED EVERYBODY IN
WASHINGTON YESTERDAY BY ANNOUNCE
WASHINGTON YESTERDAY BY ANNOUN E
ANNOUNCING HER RESIGNATION.
EVER SINCE, A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
WHO OUGHT TO REPLACE HERE.
ONE OF THE NAMES WE HEARD MOST
IS DINA POWELL.
SHE WAS A WHITE HOUSE ADVISER.
SHE SEEMS LIKE A NICE PERSON.
IS SHE THE RIGHT PERSON OR THE
THE JOB?
THAT'S THE QUESTION.
SHE'S WORKED ON BEHALF OF
VIRTUALLY EVERY IDEA THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP RAN AGAINST IN
HIS 2016 CAMPAIGN.
TRUMP, YOU'LL REMEMBER, SAID IT
WAS TIME FOR AMERICA TO ACT ON
ITS OWN BEHALF AND TO AVOID
COUNTLESS AND COUNTER PRODUCTIVE
WARS.
ARE THEIR POWELL'S VIEWS?
THEY'RE NOT.
SHE WAS A PARTNER AT GOLDMAN
SACHS.
SHE WAS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
FOUNDATION ARM.
SHE WORKED WITH THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION AND THEY WORKED
TOGETHER ON VARIOUS GOALS THAT
MOST TRUMP VOTERS WOULD REFUND
REPUGNAN
REPUGNANT.
WE'LL GET TO HEAR A LOT MORE IN